[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome back
from lunch
hope you had a pleasant one
time to resume our public hearings we're
now going to open the public hearing on
this bill is also one of the early bills
assigned to our committee which means we
have to complete our work on this bill
and report out on it by the 17th of
february
with that said i'd like to now introduce
the prime sponsor of the bill
committee member rebecca mcwilliams to
introduce the legislation
thank you
thank you very much chair bose and
esteemed members colleagues of the
science technology and energy committee
it is my absolute pleasure to be here
today to introduce bill 1506
this is meant to be an enabling
legislation bill
we are
i am proposing this bill to create a
fund
this is a self-funding fund
it uses no monies from the state of new
hampshire it's meant to be revolving
and
fund itself through the years
by giving out loans collecting interest
on those loans and then returning the
money back to the fund to be reused
again in the future
so i'm just going to go through it
briefly with you to highlight some of
the important pieces that i've
introduced um i would certainly welcome
questions on this once i'm complete and
i want to apologize but i do have to zip
out of here at 1 30 to introduce another
bill downstairs so i'll be as brief as i
possibly can to get through this
thank you
so
let's start at the top
the definition section of this bill the
focus here is really on just defining
some of the terms that we're looking to
fund with this revolving clean energy
fund
first is alternative fuel vehicles i
know we've had some interesting
discussions in this committee about
hydrogen vehicles
certainly those are included in the
definition
we're also looking at zero emissions
vehicles and of course hybrids
we've talked about this pretty
extensively in prior hearings but just
as a reminder
there certainly seems to be a trend in
transportation to be moving away from
diesel and gasoline and so this fund is
looking to provide some kind of
financing incentive for places like
municipalities here would be a good
example
if the city of franklin decided that
they wanted to go
zero emissions with their school buses
this is the sort of fun that they would
look to
for a zero or low interest loan in order
to do that and payback turns up up to 30
years once again we're not talking about
state funds to provide this this would
be funded from either federal government
funds private funds
or other sources of money
i'm going through the definitions just a
little bit further
we've talked quite a bit about energy
efficiency in this committee
so obviously if you have an existing
building perhaps once again i'll just
use franklin as an example you have a
school that needs to be insulated this
is the sort of fund where the town of
franklin could come to the fund and
request a certain amount of money in
order to do insulation projects on an
moving on
we've talked about greenhouse gases
and obviously the goal here is to reduce
greenhouse gases by moving to
incentivize
certainly micro grids would be a
potential project if you have
say a non-profit that wants to
get together and create a micro grid and
is asking for a loan in order to do so
that would be something that the
department of energy would consider
and perhaps award them alone in order to
then kind of moving down
we've got all kinds of qualified
projects which would include solar
window geothermal
certainly there are some types of
technology that we can't even imagine 10
years from now be maybe the hot new
thing
and i do think that hydrogen vehicles
may be one of those
so the fund is intended to be flexible
enough so that as it's self-funding and
moving through the next 10 to 20 years
we're not ruling out certain types of
technology that have not become
mainstream today but may be mainstream
so i'm just gonna skip ahead to page
three
this is a really important part of the
bill in terms of defining
who um
who we're intending to benefit with this
revolving clean energy fund
i've defined vulnerable communities
using the federal department of housing
and urban development guidelines
so when we're talking about a low-income
community and as written and introduced
this bill does prioritize 40 of funds
annually to go to
projects that are in low-income
so we're talking about hud guidelines
um
and in addition uh we we do want to make
sure that some of these areas as we've
heard in testimony at this committee
perhaps already are in a community where
they're
they're having compromised air quality
so that would be something to consider
when you're looking at okay this is a
community that is
currently breathing in some kind of
contaminated air
perhaps we want to make sure that we can
give them some funding to offset that
concern for health issues in the long
term
the idea here is to incentivize
low and zero greenhouse gas emission
projects
these finance tools that we're creating
here
could include a match from the private
sector
so i'm looking at perhaps we have banks
who would be interested in investing in
a community project could be school
buses for franklin
and would be willing to provide matching
funds with the same terms as the loan in
order to double the impact
through this enabling vehicle to have a
bucket to receive funds and apply them
i already mentioned that 40 percent of
investment activity of the fund is
directed to serve vulnerable communities
as defined with the head hud guidelines
and i i do want to draw your attention
to page four uh this is clause
six
it's written vi roman numeral vi clause
six page four
um the goal here is low interest and
zero interest loans and this is not a
mandate it says the department shall
explore establish a program
to provide low interest and zero
interest loans up to 30 years in length
to any school
municipal planning organization or
non-profit seeking financing for the
acquisition of zero greenhouse gas
emissions vehicle fleets
or associated infrastructure think
charging stations perhaps
to support zero greenhouse gas emissions
vehicle fleets so really this is meant
to kick off what we see as the next step
in transportation
for all of our communities but
really incentivizing our municipalities
to be able to do that and access this
kind of loan funds
i did include a clause
about
prevailing wage
for projects over a hundred thousand
dollars that may be a little aggressive
i'm not sure we're gonna get there in
year one through five but if the fund
gets that big that they can give out
funds of a hundred thousand dollars then
for construction i think it makes sense
to stay at prevailing wage
since the fund is administered by the
state agency
um and then finally the requirements
that the department
of energy create publicly available
reports i'm on page five at the top
describing um
what happened with the fund this year
what was it spent on what was the return
what was the interest what are our loan
terms and what percentage are we getting
back for these capital investments
it also allows the department of energy
to accept and use philanthropic funds so
i know we do have a couple of tech
billionaires in new hampshire and i
would invite them
verbally to please donate to kick off
this accelerator fund because i think
this is the future of the state
and just a note on the fiscal note which
is the last page of your handout um
obviously we don't have a commitment
right now from our federal delegation
and we don't have a bill signed from
washington saying
let's send money to new hampshire for
new clean tech projects but the idea of
this bill is to create a bucket so that
we are ready when that happens
and the funds can come in here and be
administered by the department of energy
so with that i'm happy to take questions
and once again i just want to remind you
okay thank you uh representative uh
bernardi uh by the way uh representative
mick williams thank you for
uh a thorough explanation of the bill
thank you for submitting the bill and
helping us understand what it's all
about
uh representative bernardi is recognized
for a comment
thank you chairman paulson uh thank you
mr
mcwilliams
so since none of this is requiring state
funds why can't this entire program be
done by a non-profit you set up a
non-profit to do this and you don't need
any legislation at all to move forward
i don't believe the federal government
would give the funds to a non-profit i
do believe the federal government would
give the funds to our department of
energy
i'm not sure
follow-up
i'm not sure that's true i think the
federal government has given all kinds
of funds to various non-profits with
specific uh jurisdictional
uh
claims made as part of their charter
sure so when you talk about a non-profit
receiving funds from the federal
government there's typically an rfp
process with a grant application correct
so we're talking about you know let's
just call it the green fund the new
hampshire green fund it's a new
nonprofit newly created
the federal government puts out an rfp
and says we're going to
create potential grants up to
x dollars you can compete and apply
submit your application get the funds
and then do what we allow you to do
within the rfp rules so that would be a
small slice
of what is potentially available as
directed to the state of new hampshire
through larger federal legislation so
what you're describing would be taking
maybe a 16th of a slice of the pizza pie
when really what i'd like is the pizza
pie
representative fletch is recognized
thank you mr chair
uh representative williams i'm reading
through this bill
and on page three i see vulnerable
communities and the first two are income
based and then the third one you say
communities of color and tribal
communities
which include a geographically distinct
area with the population of colors
higher than the average population of
color of the state how does color make a
page three this is uh section three
communities of color and tribal
communities yes okay
so what we're talking about is
historically marginalized communities
we do have a long track record as
the united states of america and to a
lesser extent as the state of new
hampshire
for marginalizing communities of color
and putting them in a position where
they have less access to real estate
less access to shared benefits such as
schools
parks open space
and so the intent here is to make sure
that we are prioritizing rectifying past
wrongs by addressing the history of how
we have addressed communities of color
could you give me an example
so redlining in terms of allowing
highways to come through areas that were
considered to be
communities of color
when we set up our zoning
or zoning in new hampshire has been
based on single-family residences one to
two acre minimums
that would be considered the antithesis
it's on that it's on now okay thank you
thank you mr chairman they take my
question following up on that i'm trying
to figure this out what is a community
of color
uh how do you define that is it based on
race national origin or what because if
it is based on either of those it seems
to me it's distinctly unconstitutional
because we have provisions in both the
new hampshire and united states
constitution that you don't discriminate
on the basis of race or national origin
so what is the community of color if
it's not based on at least partly based
on those things
so i think it's pretty clear here when
we look at census data i'm sorry i
couldn't understand what jesus said let
me move my microphone closer
when we look at census data
self-reported by people who respond to
the 10-year census
we have data for new hampshire showing
that there are communities where people
report to be
not white correct
it's self-reported in the census data so
we're looking at a municipality where
over 50 percent has reported
self-reported as not white
according to the terms of this
introduced bill
that would fall into a
distinct area in which the population of
color is higher than the average
population of color in the state
up mr chairman follow up okay uh well
first of all not following your logic
lightly because you talked about over 50
and let's be quite honest about it no
matter how you define
broadly defined communities of color we
don't have 50 percent of communities of
color in new hampshire so it's more like
five or six percent would be the
statewide average or maybe 10
so
but even it's what you just said getting
back to it says they define themselves
as non-white so it's racially based so
you're going to say based on the
community's racial makeup they may or
may not qualify for additional money how
is that constitutional
so i mentioned earlier to representative
plett's question we're talking about
rectifying past wrongs to communities of
color who have been marginalized and
with our own policies we have created it
difficult for them to accumulate
generational wealth i know that was in
the constitutional issue so we're
talking about rectifying a past wrong
when you try to use a constitutional
argument what you're saying is
when we look to the letter of the law
that's how we should behave but when we
look to history we see that that's not
how we have historically behaved
uh representative harrington you weren't
here this morning
but i went over the ground rules for the
committee this morning and one of the
ground rules is we do not debate
people when they're testifying on bills
so
there's plenty of time for that in our
subcommittees and in our executive
sessions so just refine confine yourself
to questions please thank you
i
i'm wondering how this fund is going to
work if you have
ten thousand dollars
and you give out ten thousand dollars
and it's going to take twenty
to thirty years to pay it back
does that mean you need ten thousand
dollars every year for twenty or thirty
years
to catch up in other words as as people
pay back
you're going to add back to the fund
correct
so maybe i'm wrong okay i think you're
asking about how it's administered if
the full value of the fund was ten
thousand dollars it would not be
possible to give out the ten thousand in
one year because that's the full value
of the fund
you have to hold money back in the fund
in order to accumulate interest
and keep it going and also be collecting
loan interest from small loans that
you've made out so from an accounting
perspective you can't possibly give out
the full value of the fund each year in
order for it to be a revolving fund it
would be more like three to four
thousand that you'd give out in one year
and then start collecting that interest
and additional funds from other sources
follow-up
just a quick follow-up so you would need
to add
whether it be ten thousand or a million
or ten million you'd need to add to that
fund
every year
it wouldn't be just the interest that's
coming back you would need to add
more capital
so when we're talking about a startup
right this is the your first year of a
revolving fund
if you had a hundred thousand which i
think is probably a more realistic
starting number than ten thousand
you would probably be giving out some
smaller percentage and i don't play an
accountant on tv
but you would be giving out a smaller
percentage in year one and also actively
working to solicit donations
and collect interest on the loans you've
given out in order to sustain the fund
and it was mentioned in the fiscal note
so i want to mention it here in
testimony you would also need to be
paying even if it's a part-time salary
for someone to administer the finances
of the fund so within the department of
energy i imagine there would be at least
a part-time person who would be
responsible for administering this fund
and their salary would be taken from the
fund
so it is a bit of a balancing act to
kick it off and start
and perhaps we start slow but really it
depends on how much money is in the pot
in order to do that you certainly don't
want to exhaust the pot by giving out
the full amount
but you want to be realistic about
economy and market growth and where you
can get your money back from a
short-term loan with perhaps higher
interest rates
thank you you're welcome
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative mcwilliams for bringing
this bill um i know you have to run my
question also has to do with the funding
aspects of the bill
it sounds to me like it's a little bit
of a chicken and egg when i'm reading
the fiscal note that um you know we
don't have any money to start it up but
until we have the bucket that you talked
about
we also can't go start soliciting money
for the green bank concept so i wonder
if you could
uh speak to
where you got the idea or if you know of
other green banks
regionally or
wherever that could give us an example
of how this works in practice
sure um
i i think you can just look to our
neighbor maine
for a similar program which they enacted
last summer
so maine has a newly started green bank
but instead of focusing their efforts on
municipalities and non-profits maine has
actually been providing individual loans
to individuals who own residences and
would like to upgrade to heat pumps
so it's a very different approach to
provide loans to individuals as a bank
rather than providing loans to larger
entities so it's really a question of
what you're trying to affect with a
green bank
i think maine has done a good job of in
very small instances with small loans
getting across the finish line but
knowing that if it is a 10-year term
they're not going to see their return
for quite some time
follow-up mr chairman follow up
yes and so in that light uh has the
department of energy i think they're
here and they i don't know if they're
going to testify but have they given you
any input in terms of how they would
view
uh who who would be the recipients
because i think your bill tries to
specify that
but
if this bill passes would they also have
input as to how
loans would be administered since the
department of energy would be the
administrator
well the way this bill is written
it gives great latitude to the
department of energy to looking into
different projects different ways to
fund
and different incentivizing mechanisms
so it certainly gives
the department of energy the ability to
do that i have not had any individual
conversations and i am sincerely looking
forward to the department of energy's
testimony on this bill
because as i said it would create
another position that would be funded by
the revolving fund thank you
thank you i know you uh you have to run
it's 122 that clock is fast
but i have just one quick question on
the fiscal note
my fat fingers can turn the page the
clean energy and sustainability
accelerator fund is that a fund that
exists today or is that
a fund that may be
being proposed in legislation that
hasn't been federal legislation that
hasn't been passed yet you know exactly
what that
can you just point out where it is in
the fiscal note i'm sorry i'm trying to
find it
excuse me at the very bottom of the
table in the fiscal note
where it says funding source
it checks the box called other and then
beside that it says clean energy and
sustainability accelerator fund
you know what that is so hypothetically
if there were a national nonprofit
that was a clean energy and
sustainability accelerator it could
donate to this
bucket
and
we know that there is federal
legislation currently in debate
to fund energy projects in different
states
so those two buckets either non-profit
donations into or federal money coming
into would potentially be funding
sources for this fund
okay thank you the the way this is
written it sounds like it's the actual
name of an existing fund or a proposed
fund
and i'd be interested to know whether
it's existing or proposed we will find
that one question for department of
energy okay okay thank you
um
representative samsic would like a
question if you have time
thank you very much mr chairman and
representative mc williams
listening to you it reminds me of
how very successful so-called micro
loans have been all over the world
so that financial institutions now are
very interested in doing that because
they usually never default and are very
effective do you see any analogy between
a fund like this and how micro loans are
are handled
certainly i think this is drafted along
the lines of how a micro loan could be
handled but once again there's wide
latitude for how the department of
energy decides to administer this
so it could be done in a very similar
way to micro loans with decent interest
rates very short term payback when you
say micro loan it's usually less than a
year payback
which i think would be to representative
kelly pitt's question very helpful to
have the funds coming back for a project
okay thank you representative mick
williams for an excellent introduction
of the bill and good luck with your
subsequent introduction thank you very
much
all right i would like to next call on
josie gage representing the office of
the consumer advocate she's requested uh
five minutes to testify on this bill and
has
handed out written testimony to all of
us so ms gage
the floor is yours thank you for being
here good afternoon and thank you
my name is josie gage and i'm director
of economics and finance at the office
of the consumer advocate
this is my first time testimony
testifying before this committee so
please forgive me for reading
written testimony um for anyone who
doesn't already know the office of the
consumer advocate represents the
interests of residential utility rate
payers
i'm in favor of this bill
and the oca believes that this bill is
good for residential ratepayers as it
provides capital for clean energy
technologies energy efficiency and
sustainability measures without relying
on ratepayers to fund the various
possible innovations
whether you believe in global warming
climate change or any related crises
it can be agreed upon that innovation is
economically worthy of attention as well
as the fact that it is penny wise
to use every bit of energy carefully
who's mother hasn't told us we're not
heating the outdoors
or to turn off lights when you're not in
the room
it doesn't matter matter whether you
feel affinity for saving the environment
from demise or whether you follow your
in the current instance you have the
opportunity to create an accelerator
fund that doesn't cost new hampshire's
ratepayers further
and through which rate payers stand to
benefit from investment in technology
energy efficiency and sustainability
efforts
further this bill will presumably limit
increases in funds needed through system
benefits charges related to the hotly
debated energy efficiency resource
standard and its triennium planning
additionally the amount to which new
hampshire is home to energy technologies
that reduce its dependence on wholesale
energy markets
the lower overall energy costs in new
hampshire will be
because new hampshire is the most
dependent state
on iso new england pricing and because
new hampshire must make up for what it
lacks in distributed generation
generation resources our ratepayers pay
disproportionately
more money overall for energy
the types of investments presented in
this bill aid in resetting the balance
such that new hampshire's rate payers
can reach equal footing with those on
our borders
it is it is the oca's opinion that a
prudently managed finance program that
directs investment toward efforts to
make new hampshire even more
self-sustaining while not needing to
change rate to charge rate payers is in
everyone's self-interest
thank you for sharing your time with me
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
uh representative harrington has a
question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question um
just try to make this quick there's a
second and last paragraph there you said
that
because new hampshire is the most
dependent state on iso new england
pricing and because new hampshire must
make up for what it lacks on distributed
generation sources our rate pay is paid
disproportionately more money
overall for energy could you present
some facts to back that up with some
figures i'm not saying right off the top
of your head today but if you could
submit them to the committee because
that's a pretty bold statement that i've
never heard before i'm not even sure
what it means we're the most dependent
state on iso new england pricing since
all states
are that other than extreme northern
maine so if you could get back to us
with an explanation of that paragraph
i'd appreciate it
thank you
okay
any other questions for ms gage
seeing none i thank you ms gage for your
testimony appreciate you being here
thank you
and i would like now to call on
griffin roberge from the department of
griffin did not uh indicate that he
needed any particular amount of time
but he will answer questions if needed
thank you for being here griffin thank
you mr chairman
for the record uh griffin roberge from
the new hampshire department of energy
as i mentioned this morning uh three
days into the new job so if you could
give me just a little bit of rope here
um what was it um
so thank you for the opportunity to
testify on house bill 1506
um the department is neutral on this
bill as written however and i didn't
indicate on the pink slip but
i'll do it here i just wanted to
indicate some
technical
concerns that we wanted to raise
obviously as expressed in the fiscal
note i think the department is operating
under the assumption that
the fund would be capitalized by funds
from national clean energy and
sustainability accelerators federal
grant funds or gifts as i think the
committee is aware of there has been
there have been
discussions in washington on a
reconciliation bill
and while there are discussions in
washington about providing such federal
funding for clean energy and
sustainability accelerators nothing has
been signed into law to date
going through the bill
there are a number of things that
requires the department to do in regards
to the fund
per the fiscal note the department does
not currently administer any loan
programs directly
and does not monitor local wages
therefore these new duties could not be
absorbed by existing staff nor could
these duties be paid for by utility
assessment
there i am specifically referencing page
lines 27 to 30 where it references um
monitoring local wages and that type of
thing
and again we don't monit we don't manage
any active
loan programs as i think the committee
is aware of we do oversee
the renewable energy fund but those are
largely grant driven
a couple of other technical
concerns i wanted to raise is at least
again on page 4
lines 22
it's unclear what the department should
do if there's a conflict between those
two provisions so
line 22 references that the department
shall maximize the reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions in this state
for every dollar deployed by the fund
and then line 25 says the department
shall ensure that 40 of investment
activity from the fund is directed to
serve vulnerable communities so for
example what if in order to attain a
maximum reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions you know there needs to be a
less than 40 percent of investment
activity that's left available to serve
vulnerable populations that's one
um
second concern um on page
apologies page four
um
line 34 a little bit
to borrow from representative mcgee kind
of chicken and egg situation kind of
develops um the department can only pay
staff on income from loans that have
been issued but in order to review
applications and to make loan awards the
department needs to hire staff
it's unclear if other types of funding
would allow the department to pay for
staff from the capitalized fund and
again depending on what the federal
legislation says i can't speak for
certain as to whether or not the federal
law would allow
funds to be used to pay for state staff
um
and another observation is in general
it's not clear from the language of the
bill
if the department would be permitted to
enter into a contract
for loan servicing with a third party
such as community development finance
authority the business finance authority
a credit union or a bank
and then finally
the bill doesn't provide the department
with any specific rulemaking under rsa
541-a to establish the details of the
loan fund such as interest rate setting
process loan term excuse me loan terms
application forms
annual rounds versus rolling
applications type of thing um
so yeah those are at least just the
immediate observations of the department
and certainly willing to answer any
questions if need be
and that concludes my testimony well
thank you very much for that testimony
you mentioned something that i thought
was quite interesting the business
finance authority currently implements a
revolving loan fund that is funded by
reggie funds
and is administered to pay for energy
efficiency
project loans to municipalities and
and um
school districts
with this kind of a green accelerator
fund
find a better home in the business
finance authority than in the department
of energy i i i guess i would defer to
the to the prime sponsors to what her
intentions are with that language
again just from the language as as it's
in the bill
it puts a lot of this the burden of
managing the fund on the department so
but the language isn't clear as to
whether or not the department would be
in would be able to enter into a
contract with say the business finance
authority to manage funds like that
to follow up on that the reason i
brought that up is because the bfa does
have the staff to do that they're
already doing it for several other kinds
of revolving funds and so yeah and again
that that's something subject to the
sponsors of the bill as to what they
want to do it's just a
technical concern that the department
raised in reviewing the bill
uh representative plett is recognized
for a question yes thank you mr chairman
speaking as clerk
you had uh covered quite a few points
there i never took shorthand in school
do you have uh
written notes that you could share i
could certainly show them after the
committee via email as the former aide
to the senate energy and natural
resources committee and taking notes i
can certainly understand some difficulty
in doing that so yes i can forward that
okay uh any other questions for mr
roberge
representative harrington is recognized
uh
shorthand i'd have to look through the
bill to to do a deeper dive but it off
the top of my head i didn't see it i'm
not saying it's not there i'm just
saying i couldn't answer your question
any additional questions for
mr roberge
seeing none
i'll thank you mr roberge for your
testimony thank you members of the
committee and
suggest that we close this public
hearing on house bill
welcome back at two o'clock for our next
bill which will be house bill 1601 fn
we're in
okay everyone it is now officially two
o'clock
time to start our next public hearing
which is on house bill
1601-f
n
and
this is another of the early bills
that our committee must complete its
work on by the 17th of february but
before i introduce the prime sponsor
i wanted to read something that i just
got
from
the
deputy legislative budget assistant
in the office of the legislative budget
assistant
says good morning chairman votes and
representative wilhelm
we noticed that hb 1419 which is a bill
we heard earlier this morning
has a fiscal note attached to the bill
the fiscal note was attached in error
and was intended for an earlier version
of the bill during the lsr phase
the bill is introduced no longer
contains an appropriation therefore the
attached fiscal note is not needed
sorry for the confusion that this might
cause
so that answers the questions or some of
well that's a good question because it
it didn't have an fn after it had a dash
a
it's almost a good bill okay
all right so let's move on to 1601 and i
would like to recognize
uh the ranking member
representative peter sabsitz to
introduce this bill to us
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
um
i have some
short uh written comments and i handed
copies out to everyone i believe who's
on the committee
um so the purpose of this bill is to
ensure that as the reggie auction price
increases
so too will the proceeds that are
dedicated to the energy efficiency fund
which are used to fund energy efficiency
programs and low-income energy
efficiency measures administered by new
hampshire safes
currently the first dollar from each
reggie allowance is allocated to the
energy efficiency fund
while the remaining proceeds are rebated
to electricity rate payers
according to a letter this committee
recently received from former puc chair
diane martin
the price of those allowances is
projected to increase significantly
perhaps doubling in the next several
years
however if such an increase occurs
the revenue allocated to the energy
efficiency fund will not increase
since it is based on that one dollar
allocation
instead of a percentage of the allowance
price that is why this bill proposes to
change the one dollar allocation to a 15
percent
allocation of the allowance price
since a 15 allowance for the 2021 reggie
allowance price would result
in a revenue for the energy efficiency
fund of 4.9 million
in contrast to the current 3.46 million
which is equal to 11 percent currently
the bill would set a floor for the for
future revenues at that 4.9 million
level
if a 15 take of future allowances is
higher
the
energy efficiency fund would receive
higher allocation amounts however that
allocation would not sink below that 4.9
million floor set in 2021
since the purpose of the reggie system
was to assist in funding energy
efficiency programs
it only makes sense that when reggie
allowance prices go up so does the
funding for energy efficiency programs
the amount being rebated likewise will
rise as the reggie allowance price
increases as well
and i'd like to point out that some of
this information is on the
the fiscal note table
uh on uh
right below the uh
the uh category of methyl methodology
uh so you can see that currently
according to
uh this fiscal note
under the current law we have a 33
million dollar
worth of auction proceeds
there is a administrative cost of 0.35
million that's deducted
and the remainder
32.65 million is distributed
and the energy efficiency fund receives
3.46 million dollars currently
which which
is equivalent to about 11
of the current allowance price that is
being used for this calculation
and because i assumed according to uh
chairwoman martin's comments that those
allowance prices will go up
significantly
i thought it only prudent that the
energy efficiency fund also receives
more money and not stay at the current
level
which it would do if we just kept the
one one dollar allocation
i did suggest 15
which if you can see in the second
column there under proposed amendment if
if we had 15 percent now in place that
would be uh a bit one and a half million
dollars more for the energy efficiency
fund
than is now the case
but i am setting that just basically as
a floor so that in the future if there's
if the revenues are or the allowance
price is not high enough
it would never drop below that 4.9
million
uh floor
so that's
all my testimony and i'm going to
entertain questions
answer okay thank you representative
sausage for
this interesting bill and for
introducing it to us uh representative
plett is recognized for a question
thank you mr chair is there anything
magic about the 15 percent there's
something you
pull out of the air to get the numbers
you want
uh thank you representative platt for
that question no there's nothing magical
about it except that when i put together
the lsr initially
the allowance price that i was aware of
was a different price
so that
the one dollar would have equated to 15
percent at the time
i didn't know what the number was that
the the department was calculating using
uh but at the time i was using a
difference allowance price and that's
how i came up with the 15
it could be lower like i said right now
it's 11 based on their allowance price
but that's not a magical number at all
that's certainly a number that can be
changed modified
in the future or whenever no
representative harrington is recognized
for a question
uh thank you thank you for taking my
question representative um just a
question on the the
second paragraph there at the end it
says however that allocation would not
sink below the 4.9 million so the regi
system was set up to basically
try to get rid of fossil fuel we use
less fossil fuel generation so if that
goal is met in as we go into the future
there's going to be less reggie money so
what happens if the money goes down and
it sinks below that amount and there
just be less rebate to the rate payers
like we do now
uh thank you ursula harrington for the
question can you just clarify when you
say going down are you talking about the
allowance price going down or the total
revenue that comes in going down
well the total revenue going down in the
future well well the reason i ask that
is because as you can see from
comments here on the on the fiscal note
that that allowance amount is scheduled
to decrease every year
so you've got decreasing allowances
every year and then you've got the issue
of the allowance price
so both together give you the revenue so
when you say if it goes down
are you saying if the allowance price
goes down or maybe you can just clarify
i'm sorry if the you you when you
sentence you said if the allocation
would not sink below 4.9 million floor
set in 2021 yes so if
if this increase
let's say it's going to happen for a
short term and then it doesn't it's the
revenues go down
it would but any case matter how far
down they went it wouldn't go below the
4.9 million that's my intention yeah
but based on what uh chairwoman martin
told us she's expecting it to go up so
any further questions i have a question
if allowances go down by 118
725 allowances per year
if there are fewer allowances
won't the
you know thank you very much mr chair
for this question
i can't i can't claim to be an expert on
this because obviously there are a lot
of moving parts here uh
it just
jolted my mind when i saw the letter
from chairman sherwood martin that she's
predicting as much as a doubling of that
allowance price i don't know what that
is based on whether it is because we
have fewer allowances and the demand
goes up or whether other states
that are part of the system are driving
that price up without us i'm not exactly
sure in fact i see people here from the
department of environmental services who
probably could answer that better than i
could
thank you yes that's that's
undoubtedly true and we will ask them
thank you
there's one figure here one one thing
you said that's troubling to me
and i want to make sure i'm interpreting
it correctly
one was that there was 3.46 million
dollars given out and 3.5 million
administrative fee
it's called
did i get that all wrong
oh 350 000 dollars
is is the administrative fee not 3.5
million no no no in the table here it
says current law
it lists less administrative
and it's
0.35 million so 350 000 okay yeah
follow up representative kelly pitts no
thank you okay
any further questions for representative
sausage
seeing none thank you representative for
introducing the bill
and we have quite a few people who want
let's uh let's go next to representative
tony kaplan
representative
please uh
settle in and welcome to science
technology and energy glad to have you
here
thank you mr chairman
and thank you honorable members of the
scientific technology committee
i'm here today to testify in favor of hb
which would amend reggie revenue
distribution so that energy efficiency
programs are again prioritized as was
the original intention behind the
auction allowance system of the reggie
when it was first established
the decision to provide income from the
allowances as direct rebates to
customers was politically motivated not
a science-based decision
contrary to the intent of the program
quoting font from the regi website the
reggie is a cooperative effort among 11
states
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
not provide rebates to utility customers
it's high time to set aside partisan
interpretations of the importance of
energy efficiency measures and the
strategy of reduction of greenhouse
gases
the science of climate change and the
impacts of climate change are no longer
debatable or theoretical
refusing to take action on low-hanging
fruit of energy efficiency measures is
not only in bad faith to the original
intent of the reggie program
but is pennywise pound foolish in the
extreme and in my opinion the symptom of
a suicidal mentality a death wish that
has taken hold of a system that cannot
even lift the merest finger of social
policy to save itself and a habitable
home for its descendants
it's no exaggeration to say that history
will not judge well of us
when we allow ideology to trump our
ability to engage in any sort of
communal effort to cut
unnecessary emissions of atmosphere
damaging gas from fossil fuel combustion
as represented by the reggie program and
the distribution of allowances
towards concrete steps to enhance energy
efficiency of our homes and businesses
anybody who thinks that it doesn't make
sense to spend money on energy
efficiency that's too costly or somehow
not fair to anybody is not looking at
the whole picture or looking at the
picture through the lens of an
antiquated and self-interested ideology
that lack of proper framing will cost
this dearly and when i say us
i include my children and grandchildren
and that's why i take it personally
as a matter of fact the energy
efficiency measures carried out through
the new hampshire saves program
administered by the electric and natural
gas utilities
are a strong success story and an
integral part of our economy despite not
because of their chronic underfunding
for every dollar invested over three
dollars of economic benefits are derived
from 2018 to 2020 that translated into a
net for the economy of more than half a
billion dollars and in the process
crucially to the mission i mentioned at
the outset cut almost three and a half
million tons of carbon dioxide from the
state's greenhouse gas emissions a
significant portion
of the state's emissions in that
two-year period
so now is not the time to relax our
efforts as i said the need to continue
to cut carbon dioxide emissions is not
debatable
new hampshire saves plays a crucial role
in building a sustainable 21st century
economy for new hampshire and reggie
funds should be going where they are
intended towards cutting emissions of
greenhouse gases
not blanket subsidies for electric and
natural gas customers
thank you representative
it's
unfortunate that you couldn't testify in
front of this committee
on and i will ask
mike fitzgerald from the new hampshire
department of environmental services if
he could make himself available to
good afternoon mr chairman
good afternoon
members of the committee mike fitzgerald
i'm the assistant director of the
department of environmental services air
resources division
we administer the regis program in
coordination with the department of
energy
we we manage the auctions
and
the revenue goes into the department of
energy where where it's dispersed
under rsa 125.0
i know mr roberts is here from the
department of energy but
i think most of the questions that you
have
at this point relate to the
auction revenues and what might happen
here so we'll try to answer those and
if we don't know the answer we'll throw
mr roberts under the bus i mean uh defer
to
defer to him but
i think we'll we'll we'll give it a shot
so i have with me also joe fontaine
who's the reggie program manager um he
actually is
the person who is involved um on a
day-to-day basis with conducting the
auctions
managing the
the revenue auction prices and all that
so
i may
want to have him
assist me in responding to some of these
questions
i think the department takes no position
on the bill by the way
okay thank you uh welcome back uh both
of you to the committee good to see you
both again thank you
we do have questions uh i'll recognize
first representative thomas for a
question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question and again welcome back as
well good to see you back here thank you
uh i want to refer back to a previous
comment made for some explanation for my
benefit and perhaps for the benefit of
one of our new members here on on the
committee could you explain to us um
what went into the
i guess i would call it a prediction
that i think i heard that the auction
prices were thought to be going up and
could even be doubled but could you
explain that uh process or
or or how that happens
yeah thank you um i'm we're not familiar
specifically with the uh letter that is
referred to from chairwoman martin um
uh as mentioned previously for those of
you who aren't familiar
uh before the department of energy was
created the regi program was
administered jointly between the puc
public utilities commission and
the
department of environmental services and
at that time chairwoman martin would
have been the reggie
energy agency representative from new
hampshire commissioner scott of des
would be the reggie environmental agency
each state has two representatives
in in the uh
management of reggie
and so
uh chairwoman martin i'm not familiar
specifically with her comments but
bottom line
prices auction revenues
joe and i were just talking it's a
market and market prices fluctuate
reggie auction prices have tended to
rise over the past several years as the
number of allowances has decreased
as you would expect
the allowances become more valuable
and that and as representative samsuch
represented
the revenue total revenue is a function
of the total number of allowances that
are available
each year
times the revenue price there are four
quarterly auctions
so you would get four prices for
uh during the year of revenues
joe the current revenue current auction
price is somewhere around 13
the last auction price was 13 yeah they
have been as low as two at the beginning
of the program um
that was when the dollar threshold was
was
established and for reference at that
time
that represented about 50 percent
in the dollar
allowance prices were two dollars and
the dollar threshold was one dollar so
one dollar went to
energy efficiency programs and one
dollar went to um
rebates to to customers so
now that it's 13
we're
at in in the under the current situation
as the fiscal note describes
basically 12 of of revenue allowance
would go to assuming it stayed at 13 for
the full four years
full four quarters of a year
of that revenue would be rebated and one
dollar would go into energy efficiency
programs under this bill that would be
revised in accordance with the
methodology that representative samsich
testified to
and thank you just a quick operational
note since neither of you have probably
worked with this new system we have here
i was just going to suggest that you
joe if you want to speak mr fontaine if
you want to speak move the microphone
great thank you yeah i was just going to
add that um i'm not sure when the letter
from commissioner martin was written
but
the the revenues have already doubled so
a few years ago they were in the 16
17 million
annual range
and then
as in the
fiscal note
this past year there were 33 million so
um
i
like to quote past numbers i don't like
to speculate on what the market's going
to do in the future
so i i wouldn't be as bold to say that
you're saying that
past performance is not an indicator of
future
okay thank you if you'd like to be our
broker
okay
representative plett
thank you mr chair
i i don't want to testify i'm just going
to lay out a scenario and see if
you could possibly see that as at least
possible
right now isil new england is discussing
minimum offer price rule and having it
possibly go away
that could have the impact of collapsing
the capacity market prices and the
energy market prices as we get flooded
with
other resources more renewable
and so uh it may drive some gen
fossil generators gas out of business
and so could you see the rigid prices
collapsing out of that unless there's a
pretty stiff price put on ancillary
you know
again it's a market
and the market would respond to to
market forces which that would certainly
be one
um
i think
it's important to understand that the
regi revenue is based on co2 emissions
not necessarily market price not not
market uh
electricity prices
so
you know i mean if there were
companies out there that were supplying
electricity and they emitted co2 they
would still need to purchase a an
allowance
if those companies collapsed
you know then and there were no market
there were no other revenues
or no other market actors to to pick up
those uh allowances then there certainly
could be a
a decline in in prices and perhaps a
precipitous one but
um
somebody somebody has to generate
electricity and the demand for
electricity isn't going away and if
they're if it's from my fossil fuel
power plant that's 25 megawatts or
greater it's going to they're going to
representative samsuch it's not
typically
allowed for
a sponsor of a bill to ask questions
uh during the bill's public hearing
however
i'm going to allow it just this one time
just one question please
thank you mr chairman i just want to
clarify something that joe just said
and also the fiscal note um because i
didn't write the fiscal note but when i
look at the fiscal note i look at the 33
million that's listed here and i divide
that by the allowance amounts that are
listed in the fiscal note
i get a price of 9.53
you just mentioned the most recent
auctions were 13
which is kind of a shock or so but but
just points out that
apparently there can be quite a swing in
prices
is that correct there were four auctions
in 2021
the first auction
was in the seven dollar range and then
the december auction was the thirteen
dollars okay so
thank you very much that range
is out to the nine goals
and and again i think it's important to
remember that it's not just the price
per allowance but the number of
allowances so as that number of
allowances
decreases
there'll be a
pardon me
representative harrington thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question just just on that subject we
were just referring to there you would
mention that the price was much higher
in december than it was earlier in the
year um i'm assuming that's to do with
the fact that we've been burning a lot
more oil in coal uh in this in well
right now we're burning a lot more oil
and coal uh so going forward through
this winter was it was that the driving
no not so much
again i don't like to speculate but i
will
market
activity in the natural gas market
occurred and those prices
due to the european natural gas market
and exports to europe
uh went up significantly and so i think
they doubled
so the regime allowances
sometimes track
the natural gas price allowances
in the auctions you can have
the power plants the compliance entities
but
it's also open to
investment firms
so
um
someone can buy and retire the the
things right
well they
they're buying them to sell them at a
higher price later on that's what
they're doing so okay thank you yeah
glasses on glasses off
uh
it seems to me
that we're talking in money
and we suppose we should be talking in
percentages you mentioned that we were
at 50
when the program started
right
by virtue of the fact that allowance
prices at that time were right whatever
they were whether they were 10 cents or
10 000. so now we are looking to go up
to 15
is that
correct
that we want to give 15
of the revenues whatever those revenues
are
right is that my correct interpretation
based based on
if you're looking at the fiscal note the
fiscal note is based on a revenue of 33
million for 2021. the revenue going
forward could be a different figure
right but i'm looking
so but based on the 2021
the numbers you just cited are correct
but
okay so
help me a little bit with this math is
not my big deal
uh if we
no matter what it is
it would be 15 of that number whether it
dips or rises
but the floor would stay
the same
would the floor stay
i i'm not sure the floor i thought could
go no lower than 4.9 million
and that's what i thought it said in the
bill um so we can go up actually in the
bill um it refers to 2020
so that you might need a technical
amendment to make that 2021 if you want
the floor to be 4.9 million to keep the
floor steady 2020 it would be a lesser
amount than 4.9
may i follow up
yes ma'am
so
at the way i'm thinking very
simplistically
is that 15
back to the reggie fund or back to
energy efficiency is not going to be
catastrophic
we've been at this for how many years
since 2009
so that we've got you know that the 15
is not going to be
a big
major
problem
and would you would you concur with that
yeah if you again referring to the
fiscal note the change
uh based on the 2020 um
numbers that joe used
uh 2021 i'm sorry
uh the change would be under current law
it would be 3.46 million going into the
energy efficiency fund
under this proposed bill it would have
been 4.9 million so it would have
changed it from 3.46 to 4.9
may i
technically no
you've already asked two questions but
i will follow up if if it's okay with
you yeah
thank you
the bill says
the text of the bill on lines
17 and 18 on um
well 17 and 18 of the bill
says
that the fifth the allowance all amounts
in excess of 15 of the 2020 reggie
allowance revenue or 15 of the current
year's
reggie allowance revenue whichever is
higher
shall be rebated
so
the higher amount would always be
rebated
would be
the amount in 2020 but it could actually
be less than 13 15
in subsequent years it could go down
mr chairman i i would i would agree with
your analysis i
i just pointed that
if the
revenue allowance were to were to
decline what what the 15
the initial 15 that refers to the 2020
that would actually act as a floor
so if if the revenues were to go below
that
in any given year
that would that would be the floor and
if the intent was for the floor to be
the 4.9 it would be
you would need a technical amendment to
make that refer to 2021 instead of 2020.
correct so the floor is actually 15 of
2020. as the bill is written now yes do
we know what the the revenues were in
uh i think that we did we were doing
some expected i think we said around 21
million joe
i'd have to go back and provide that
number to you i don't have that with me
today
i had the 2019 number
was uh 16.8 million i think so it's
between 16.8 a little it's a little bit
higher
um the allowance prices in 2020 were
were less than
um
what they were in 2021.
okay
we'll certainly get back to you with
that figure
fine thank you any uh additional
questions for
these uh
exemplary gentlemen from des
representative mick williams
thank you chairvoz um i just wanted to
clarify i know
one of the introductory pieces about
this is that reggie is a multi-state
effort
um
can you just explain how other states
are handling this
reggie funding and what's going on with
rebating or not how is that handled in
other states that are part of this
reggie collaborative
um one of
one of the things that we'll provide to
following this uh we will send the
committee a link to the most recent
reggie annual report that outlines how
each state
um
delivers
states differ many
you know there are currently joe what 11
states now
currently 11 states um it's subject to
individual policy in each state
um
i think
is it probably about 60 50 60 percent
joe is is energy efficiency
of the total cumulative of the
cumulative proceeds uh
it's uh
was the most recent number so that's
total for all
total for all states about 54 goes to
energy efficiency
some some goes to rebates some goes to
other
renewables some states
yeah
massachusetts for instance used it to
fund clean clean vehicles um rebates
so there's a wide variety and we'll send
you that link that that report outlines
follow-up so
i just want to do a comparison are there
any other states of these 11 that are
rebating everything but the first dollar
back to consumers
i don't believe that there are any
states that
are
at that level well
so they're higher
in in general to the best of my
knowledge yes okay thank you
thank you okay
what for what what purpose is the member
uh
rise thank you mr chairman i would just
want to request the gentleman from des
if they could also provide us a copy of
the recent report on legislative
oversight for
electric services which
october 1st i think from craig wright
which has a lot of information relevant
to this bill
okay thank you appreciate you guys
supplying that information and
appreciate you both being here thank you
very much thank you i do have one copy
of that report that mike was referring
to that
it's for the 2019 year uh on the
proceeds with the appendix that has each
states
spending i can i can if you could send
it along i'll make sure everybody else
gets a copy i have it with me oh you
have it with you okay thank you
we can send the link
yeah the link would be better yeah link
wouldn't be better
okay
did you have
oh i'm sorry representative platt yes i
just would appreciate the
results for 20 and 20 21 as well for
every auction
okay now i guess we can uh move on and
so i will call on our next
speaker who is
a gentleman who's rapidly becoming our
new best friend
griffin rhubar robarge verge from the
good afternoon members of the committee
again
griffin roberts from the new hampshire
department of energy
the department is neutral on
committee certainly asked a lot of
questions of des
i would consider them the best experts
for you today but i'll certainly
entertain any questions that the
forget to turn on my mic anyone have any
questions for mr roberge
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman
um welcome back thank you uh
three days in i have a good one for you
yes
and uh the question is does the
department have
um
have plans to pull together
uh their own plans for energy efficiency
in the state because i think as you've
probably seen we have energy efficiency
coming at you in various forms of
legislation trying to figure out how do
we do it how do we fund it how do we
make it work no where's the right place
so i know you're new but no i
first off thank you for the question uh
representative yes i know this bill as
well as the one that's going to be heard
after which i believe
representative mann i i believe uh is
prime sponsoring that bill
um you know i think one of the more
uh talked about issues regarding energy
efficiency has been the puc's decision
on the energy efficiency resource
standard
as i'm
sure that this committee is well aware
representative votes has house bill 549
which
cleared with a unanimous vote i believe
last week in house in the house
343-0
that bill i'm sure
will be heard by the senate
relevant senate committee sometime soon
the department is monitoring the course
of that bill um
obviously
overseeing any potential changes there
coming up on that
so yes we're keeping a keen eye on that
need to follow up
yes that would be great
i guess my question is um
does the department have any preference
oh in terms of energy efficiency funding
ends up in yeah because yeah we're
trying to go after it in multiple ways
and i'm just curious whether the
department has anything no and that's
understandable i think the i think the
department at this time is just
monitoring the various legislative
proposals and is considering which one
you know
may be best to you know address the
objectives of energy efficiency in the
state um i would just say you know at
this point at this time just because
there's so much focus on it and it is
explicitly focused on the energy
efficiency resource standard in the
pucc's decision i'd say you know we're
we're closely following house bill 549
for sure
okay thank you any other questions for
mr roberge
seeing none i thank you mr roberge for
your testimony and
there are no
oh there is one more
thank you members of the community okay
where did that come from
oh okay
so now i'd like to call on brett
cherrington from hillsboro
who needs five minutes to speak
mr charrington welcome
thank you very much
and thank you to the entire
board
my name is brett charrington and uh
you've had uh plenty of experts coming
and giving you opinions and i
i'm just a citizen who is uh interested
in
energy and uh
i am uh currently the chairman of the
hillsborough energy commission
and i am
basically here to speak
towards the uh
bill which would
help to increase funding for the new
hampshire saves program new hampshire
saves is a program which
uh helps
uh
save
energy it it the energy efficiency
program is
uh
the
easy way to
improve our energy system
because we don't need more generation
we're trying to cut the amount of energy
that is saved
so you know i i'm not going to talk
about the the uh
the
numbers and all that i just
want to say that
um
from my point of view
you know we are in a situation where we
need to
revamp our entire power generation
and this is a great program and uh the
increased funding would be beneficial
and so i'm in favor of it and i'm
okay thank you we appreciate you being
here as someone who is a member of a
town energy
organization you might be
an ideal person to ask some questions
about
what you see
day to day and on the ground
opportunities for
what we all want it to be so my first
question for you would be
the public utilities commission when
they rejected the triennium energy
plan
stated in their order that they thought
that
the
utilities who administer new hampshire
saves ought to be trying to find more
private funding non-ratepayer funding
to implement energy efficiency programs
as somebody who's on the ground close to
the
[Music]
the energy
organizations in new hampshire towns do
you know of any way to any sources of
funding that could be tapped for that
process
uh
private funds um
i do not
i do not off the top of my head i i do
not okay i wasn't trying to put you on a
spot i just thought maybe because of
your unique role you might know
something that that the rest of us don't
any other questions uh for mr
charrington
representative mcwilliams
thank you chairvoz um and thank you very
much for your testimony today it is
great to get the boots on the ground
testimony so bravo really appreciate it
um i just wanted to ask from your
meetings with folks within your local
group
um have you discussed the the rebates in
reggie and do you kind of have a stance
on on whether or not this should be
altered changed continue the way it is
uh i don't recall
any discussion
exactly related to
changing
the reggie allocation
but i do know that we have recently done
a
full energy audit of all of our
municipal buildings and we are looking
to
benefit from the new hampshire saves
program
and be able to
do some of these
weatherization products on the
very old and
in need
follow-up
um
so
if
the reggie program were to increase
funding
is that something that your group would
okay but i'm not speaking for
my commission i am speaking as a citizen
so i you know i just want that to be
clear
thank you thank you for that
clarification okay any uh additional
questions from mr charrington
thank you chair and welcome
uh
i would like your on the ground
perspective i have i attended my first
the first uh
community power forum in my home
district of marlborough last night
i was pleased and happy to learn that
well eight percent of the people who
answered a survey and of course these
surveys are always self-selecting
uh said they wanted to see a reduction
in their um rates
uh the other 92 percent were either
neutral on that question or they would
be stated very clearly they'd be willing
to pay a slight amount more
if they knew the energy they were
purchasing would be of a green nature
do you find this kind of do you have
access to any kind of this kind of
information in your hillsborough
committee and i was wondering if you
could tell us what those kind of figures
are there as far as what your
um
what your committee supports and what
they see the people of hillsboro
sporting
uh
to be honest with you we do not have a
whole lot of uh
input from the from the people in town
um
we're
we have virtually no
uh public at our meetings and uh we're
just trying to get
our
job done which is to save money for the
town
and uh
we're currently uh not only doing the uh
energy audit and upgrades to the town
buildings but we're also doing a led
light
street light replacement project and you
know these are the things that we're
focusing on things that actually
will save the town money
we're going to be saving the town
uh
i think it's around
40 000 a year once the led lights are
replaced and so
that's pretty much our focus is um
saving energy and by such saving
the taxpayers money
i should add those numbers came about
because we did we are looking into uh
moving into community power and if
you're not at that point yet it's
perfectly understandable go follow up
thank you so much
thank you representative partial you
might want to share those numbers with
the committee at some point
i'd be happy to
all right any uh representative mcgee
thank you mr chair i i just had a
question you mentioned that you had just
completed an energy audit and i know i
live in hollis and we have had a very
active energy commission for a long time
and they did an energy audit years ago
based on some software that came out of
epa i was just curious how you
accomplish the audit because usually
that's where you make the decisions of
where you're going to put the money in
in your efforts
yeah we hired
uh
firm here in concord i believe is where
they're looking so local new hampshire
business
okay thank you
seeing no further questions for mr
charrington i want to thank you mr
chairman for taking the time out of your
day to come and talk to us here today
and give us in giving us your unique
perspective
thank you very much mr sherman and the
rest of the committee as well thank you
no other pink cards on the table for
house bill 1601 fn
i declare this public hearing at an end
we'll now be in recess until three
o'clock when we start a public hearing
um
okay
is
[Music]
usage
he's
so
okay good afternoon everybody
time to move on to the final public
hearing of bills before the stne
committee today
the 11th of january
this
bill hb 1621 fn is another early bill
that we must
complete our work on
by the 17th of february
and
it is with great pleasure that i
introduce the bill's sponsor
representative john mann long time
member of this committee so john take it
away thank you thank you mr chairman um
so um i just want to introduce myself a
little bit i have a bit of experience
with energy efficiency um
massachusetts
program
um
did a tremendous number on a century-old
house that my wife had bought my current
now she's my wife that she had bought in
somerville massachusetts which
i think she paid 94k for it and its
value now is uh 1.2 million um according
to
the that website that
prices houses anyway also in my own town
we've had some
fine audits by experts margaret dillon
might
be a name some of you might know if
you've been involved in that anyway
our town library we spent
we
improved their reduce the consumption of
heating oil by 58
about 50 000 worth of
funds um
i presented the project after doing a
few things with um you know programmable
thermostat and so on
um i presented the project to it the
town meeting and they voted 30
to do this job
um
uh so
you know i have as i said i've had some
experience and on for most of our
buildings in town including our school
we've been audited and we know exactly
what the situation is in all of these
and that's what energy efficiency
programs do
typically
with my daughter's house in
massachusetts
they blew insulation into the walls from
the outside shingle house they just
drill a hole
put in a pipe and this uh cellulose just
blasts up into the whole
um
column
between the two two by fours that are
typically uh what's 18 inches 24 inches
apart you just go down the house and
blow the walls full of insulation
which is the only since everything is
all sealed you need to have a funny way
like that and my wife's
house in somerville they went inside
because it had asbestos shingles like
typical manchester house
and
went inside drilled and then patched the
holes
were done in eight hours and it was a
big grand
house
so you know amer energy efficiency is a
pretty amazing thing
um
so anyway
i was in i've always been interested in
this so i attended a house hearing
uh soon after reggie was started up we
were joining reggie
there was a hearing for a bill to get us
out of reggie
and a gentleman who
identified himself as corey lewandowski
state director for americans for
prosperity
um
was sitting in the front
very close to the
and they
um there was a lot of testimony against
the bill from people in the public
and after a while the chairman looked
down at lewandowski and said
we'll never pass this bill to kill
reggie we'll go with a rebate and he was
nodding his head as if to say you know
this is the decision your
your
your hopes are all gone so anyway
that was the end of that the um the
meeting kind of erupted in uh uproar and
uh
was uh conveniently recessed until
around six at night so
that cleared up that problem so it was a
very very clever maneuver
by one of our legislative heroes um
to save the day but what it turned out
to be is a compromise was had been made
with lewandowski
again in representing americans for
prosperity that we would stay in reggie
but we'd have this one dollar
would be kept in the energy efficiency
fund to do energy efficiency and all the
rest would be retained rebated to
ratepayers
so that's the origin of this
whole situation that we're in
okay
um
turns out um
maybe years later two or three four
years later
lobbyists for one of the utilities was
at a
committee a meeting of this committee
and he showed me
that the typical rebate
despite all the money that we've been
talking about about in this last
the last bill the typical rebate is
about a dollar a month
another
uh for somebody from new england new
hampshire electric cooperative
showed me a 65 cents
a month it was a rebate so the rebate is
kind of
uh it takes a lot of money away without
providing
any meaningful benefit
to the ratepayer
unless of course you're in the business
community and you're running a factory
so that's that
problem
um
so
it turns out again if you
buy an led
or you're given an led
and you install it you're going to save
a lot of money every month
on your electric bill
because they save an awful lot of
electricity
now you can
keep that led
in maybe
two months three months four months
i think maybe in about one month a month
and a half you will have paid the price
of that led
and you can now buy a second one
and then now you have two led bulbs and
in half that time
you can buy a third
and in a third of that original time you
can buy a fourth
so without out without advancing any
money at all
anyone
given a single led
can save and
buy his way to to a complete replacement
of all the lamps in his house with led
and save any amount of rebate
that he might have been getting so
i don't feel sad for the individual
homeowner that might be losing a rebate
on his electric bill
um
so
then i
i i was discussing um
representative samsich's bill
and
it just seemed too complicated for me so
i just decided the way to solve it is
this
every year for the next eight years or i
don't know six years we'll reduce the
rebate by a dollar
now i think that'll zero it out but for
some people it won't maybe for industry
it won't
but then the next month reduce it by
another dollar so a dollar a month until
i think 2028 is the way i ended it and
that's a simple-minded
um
way of getting rid of the rebate without
having to know anything about the rebate
that's basically what the bill does
thank you
representative mann for presenting this
bill to us i have one quick question
on line three of the bill it says for
fiscal year 2021
et cetera et cetera et cetera
since we're already in fiscal year 2022
would
you be planning to file an amendment to
change that language to for fiscal year
all amounts in excess
blah blah blah sure and that's changing
the language on line five to beginning
in fiscal year 2022 is what it says now
change that to 2023. yes you would be
open to that okay yeah i guess i don't
know when i wrote this bill maybe it was
sometime last year
all right uh i'm getting old as you know
yes yes we understand so are we all and
it's preferable to the alternative right
so representative samsit should you have
a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative man for taking my
question uh i just wanted to clarify you
just mentioned something about reducing
the rebate back to the ratepayers by a
dollar a month i think you meant per
year right
not every month every month because in
your bill here it says decreasing
by one year starting
beginning in 2022
through fiscal year 227 the rebat amount
all retail elect this is line six shall
yeah but you just said per month
um
the better way to put it would be the
monthly rebate
the monthly rebate so i'll insert
monthly
so all retail electric rate payers shall
and um
so in other words it just drops
dollar and then it's a dollar less
but not every month right that's what
i'm asking no it's just the monthly
rebate oh the monthly rebate amount
will be decreased annually by a dollar
just you need to follow it
okay
um representative callie pitts
john help me
so if the
if the rebate is a dollar
or 65 cents
it would go to zero immediately
yes
okay
no the rate payer won't have to pay
no i'm kidding
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um
the
bolded letters here we just went through
changing some of the years
and it appears that you're looking to do
this over a five-year period ending in
2027 based on that bolded language if we
change 2021 to 2022 and 2022 to 2023
would you also want to be changing 2027
to 2028 yes
why not yay okay got that out clearly
thank you any more questions for
before we move on oh representative
samsic sorry uh sorry uh i i just wanted
now that we're changing the dates
on line seven it says beginning in
fiscal year 2028 the rebate amount shall
be set to zero
but
representative kelly pitts just asked
you about that and it seems like it's
going to be zero in a year
well 20 28. well that that's that
depends if the
you know the
the utility agent uh representative from
several years ago putting up you know a
dollar is the typical rebate that could
change the allowances could go up
right the the cost of an allowance goes
up and i don't understand how that works
but um i just thought
you know if it
you've got fair warning that it's going
to be zero
and it gradually gets down there and i
think that's fine and i'm and i'm just
throwing a dart at the wall frankly
so
this language won't work because the way
the program currently works
is all the money in excess of a dollar
gets rebated to customers so for example
right if if the number is 13
as it was in the december auction
uh
then the first
dollar would go back to energy
efficiency programs but the next 12
would go back to rate payers right
so decreasing this by one dollar a year
for five years
if it happens to be
twelve dollars
isn't going to get you to where you want
to go so that's right i think maybe you
need to re will that rethink this well
the um i thought of that i
it's basically says in base in beginning
in fiscal year 2020
and i'll say 9
the rebate amount shall be set to zero
and i guess i should put
yeah i said beginning in i should say
that it would continue at that level
zero
i think and i think again energy
efficiency is so
damned important
and uh house the
increase in the value of the house my
wife bought
people saying oh yeah we know it's
energy efficient you know it's one other
representative mcgee did you have a
question
okay
okay any further questions for
representative mann
seeing none
thank you representative mann for
introducing your bill thank you and i
who is
none other
than our good friend griffin roberge
of the new hampshire department of
energy
me
there we go good afternoon members of
the committee uh again for the record my
name is griffin roberge from the new
hampshire department of energy
um the department is neutral on
um house bill 1621 fn
much like the previous bill
the bill
amends the type of the level of rebate
that's rebated back to
new hampshire rate payers under the
renewab regional greenhouse gas
initiative program um
i'm certainly open to take any questions
if the committee has any
i would certainly defer any more
technical questions to
the expertise of mike fitzgerald and joe
okay questions for mr roberge
sorry the numbers of the committee have
dwindled a little bit we've we've had
because there was not a lot of advance
notice for this meeting people had other
appointments and
things scheduled so if anybody has any
oh representative mcgee thank you no
it's do you have any cards
i uh that is something i am actively
trying to get three like i said i will
be sending emails to the committee with
uh
answers to some of the questions i've
been asked a previous bill hearings so
you'll have my email phone number thank
by the way i neglected to mention that
representative platt had to leave and
representative white has volunteered to
be the clerk
for the balance of the meeting so i want
to thank representative white for
stepping up
uh mr chairman
did you representative partial you have
a question that's basic housekeeping um
mr roberts can we expect to see you at
generally every one of our upcoming
sessions
in terms of this committee meeting i i
can't comment whether or not that'll be
something on an ongoing basis uh that's
my operating assumption right now um but
i can't give you a definitive answer on
that just yet well i always hope you
feel welcome i just wonder if this is
what a format you should be expecting
that's fine so thank you so much thank
you
i'm sorry i was uh briefly distracted uh
i think you guys finished you're your
exchange okay
seeing none it looks like mr roberge is
the last person to testify on this bill
so
i will close the public hearing on house
bill 1621 fn
and before we
adjourn the meeting i would ask if there
are
any of the members any members of the
committee has anything they would like
to say
representative mick williams uh thanks
chairvoz i just have a housekeeping
question um previously we had a room off
of our hearing
space where we could store bills are we
doing that with this office or is there
another space that's assigned to us
down the hall
good good question and my apologies for
not
addressing that issue earlier
our office is still 304 that has not
changed
the file cabinets and the file drawers
in 304 are still ours
so if you want to put your stuff there
that's where you can put it we will
continue to meet in this room for the
of the year
but that room remains hours and
presumably at some point we'll be
returning to room 302 304
for our public hearings and meetings
representative mcgee i just have a
follow-on housekeeping question do we
have any sense yet if we're going to be
meeting on the same day of the week or
if we're going to be meeting weekly or
bi-weekly or
yes because you arrived early you didn't
hear that i have already scheduled
all the remaining bills for the
committee on subsequent tuesdays
starting next tuesday
so the 18th 25th february 1st and
february 8th
we will finish
all of our bills
and then we will have plenty of time for
subcommittees and executive sessions
and as a reminder we have to have all
the early bills and there are five of
them we heard four of them today we'll
hear the fifth one on
next tuesday morning
those bills all have to be finished by
the 17th of february
representative matter thank you mr
chairman i just wanted to commend you
for doing a good job on wmur and commend
everybody for voting for house bill 549.
excellent thank you very much
okay without further ado uh we will
adjourn our meeting i want to thank
everybody for being here for
helping our process run smoothly and for
asking good questions i will see you all
you